Van life lesson number one: Never underestimate the kindness of strangers.
Sometimes, it takes a village.
Sometimes, you ask for help.
Sometimes, you can't do it on your own.
We decided to do our van conversion in this donkey pen in southern Spain...
...because we thought it would be easier than building on the street,...
...below our old apartment in Berlin, during a cold and rainy German winter.
The next day started the way nearly every day would on the mountain,...
...by feeding the two donkeys, Myrtle and Nush-Nush,...
...and working from dawn till dusk on the van build.
Turns out, demolition is a great way to learn how to use power tools for the first time...
...because there's not really much you can mess up.
We wanted a clean slate...
...so that the off-grid van conversion we were undertaking would last for years to come,...
...but first, we'd need to tackle the massive rust problem...
...by removing the entire old interior of the van,...
...so we could patch the leaky windows and repaint everything to protect the metal.